following the huge success of Berg box
the apocalypse has returned to Netflix
so this time it's a swarm of prehistoric
style creatures that threatened to wipe
out humanity yippie Kay movie lovers I'm
John and in this video i'm revealing
behind-the-scenes secrets about the
monsters in the silence explaining who
the sinister cult really are and they'll
talk about how the movie compares to a
quiet place obviously spoilers ahead so
take care if you haven't seen the film
yet
the silence is pterodactyl like monsters
the vest unleashed when an
archaeological expedition opens up an
uncharted cave system deep in the
mountains the vests are an undiscovered
species that have been sealed
underground and so although they're
blind they've evolved an acute sense of
hearing so they hunt their prey by sound
the movies produced said the filmmakers
created a mythology and backstory for
the monsters where after they got stuck
in the cave system the vests adjusted to
living life in darkness with limited
resources they evolved and developed the
ability to shut down their system into a
sort of stasis and they didn't need a
lot of fuel to stay alive after the
vests escaped into the world above they
have access to a lot more food and are
therefore able to reproduce much more
quickly as allie discovers when she and
her father are at the pharmacy
these creatures lay eggs inside their
victims the vests physiology and design
is inspired by reptiles bats and birds
and they are meant to be a naturalistic
species that could have evolved on earth
director John Leonetti explained that
they research species have been found in
caves over the years and use that to
make the best biology very realistic the
skin is translucent they have wings and
they fly but they also crawl and lay
eggs like reptiles a lot of scientific
research went into the design the
creation and the computer animation of
the creatures right down to the detail
of every joint every vessel and every
move they make the filmmakers have also
said the monsters are definitely not
aliens or creatures from outer space and
they're named after the Spanish word for
wasps and ice baths as they tend to
swarm in large numbers attacking their
prey the vests ability to evolve and
reproduce so quickly is their strength
and as we see it in the very end of the
movie even though it's reported they
don't like extreme cold some of them are
now making their way north and surviving
Ally who made it to the ref
which is located in a snowy cold area is
now hunting down vests which have
invaded the territory and what's most
scary is that the vests have been laying
their eggs and the animals they've
killed in the area for example this wolf
it seems like a pretty grim apocalyptic
ending but Ali suggests there is a
possibility that humanity could survive
this disaster and beat the monsters that
are slowly overtaking the world so will
the rest of humanity evolve will we
adapt to this new world of silence and
remember what it is that separates us
from them maybe I guess it's just a
question of which of the two species
does it first
according to Ali she herself is proof
it's possible for humans to evolve after
an accident where she lost her hearing
she explains that her father was
surprised that she adapted so quickly
and as a result of that Ali and her
family learned to communicate the sign
language which meant they seemed more
equipped to live in a world where
silence means safety and noise needs to
danger or even death the final scene
which has a touch of the Hunger Games
about it shows that Ali has figured out
one way to kill the creatures is using a
bow and arrow which is obviously much
quieter than a gun that's also why
earlier in the movie you fashioned a
wooden spear as a weapon for Jude to use
at the end of the day though given how
rapidly the creature seemed to multiply
laying so many eggs surviving families
would really need a larger scale
solution such as the wood chipper Ali's
father used earlier in the film as well
as the vest the silence also has a group
of human antagonists who the family have
to deal with following Ali and her
father's trip to the pharmacy they have
their first encounter with the creepy
Reverend who tries to get them to join
his flock the Reverend leads a group or
cult called the hushed who've cut out
their own tongues and later they turn up
at the place where Ali and her family
are staying to pressure them again to
join their cult this time it's even more
creepy though because the Reverend
reveals he's after Ali in particular
because she's fertile it's never stated
explicitly but it seems the cults may be
collecting young women to use them to
breed and swell their own numbers and
repopulate the earth after the
apocalypse by the way this is a change
from the original book by Tim Leben were
the cult wanted Ali so they could
to sign and communicate silently the
hushed also seemed to be part of a
broader religious reaction to the
unleashing of this apocalyptic world at
one point in the movie when Ally's on
her tablet she Scrolls past headlines
that say religious extremists have been
breeding best to hasten the end of the
world for what they see as Judgment Day
they've also been burning atheists alive
and one preacher is reported as saying
humanity is the plague and vests of the
Cure in fact when Ali calls her
boyfriend Rob he's coughing and looks
like he's holed up some were trying to
keep safe Rob tells Ali his parents are
dead and I wonder if that's because
they've been attacked by religious
fanatics the silence also plays on the
idea of this religious cultists
terrorists when they send a young girl
into the house wearing a suicide vest
made up of cell phones ready to go off
okay so you've no doubt heard a lot of
people saying this movie's a ripoff of a
quiet place before I explain why a quiet
place is definitely a much better film
it's worth noting that the silence was
actually adapted from a book written by
Tim Leben which was published before a
quiet place came out so it's not a
ripoff even if the premise is similar
the way a choir plays executed the idea
there is much better it has a much
tighter story focusing on just one
family with Burley any other characters
or speaking in the movie and so the
tension in that film is really dialed up
to the max as a family avoids making
even a tiny noise for fear attracting
monsters stalking the land the silence
by contrast is all over the place a
family mostly talks even when they're
signing and the story moves way too
quickly taking the family from the
suburbs to the countryside and then on
to the refuge in less than 90 minutes
with a side plot of religious extremism
along the way on top of that each death
in a quiet place as much more impact
than those in the silence that's because
the silences characters are
underdeveloped so you don't care as much
about what happens to them and although
the religious cult side story is
potentially interesting it comes late in
the film and feels rushed through also
many points which come up in the film
are left hanging for example the fact
that the electric grid and internet
seems to be randomly working and then
sometimes not is it because the
creatures have been taking down power
lines I mean we have seen the mass
on the powerlines or is it something
else like both a quiet place and bird
box showed the idea of a creature
preying on one of your senses can set up
a very interesting horror movie and the
silence like those two other films also
has a good cast including Kiernan Shipka
stanley tucci and veranda also
unfortunately though they can only
really do their best with the material
they're given which doesn't live up to
either a quiet place or bird box a quiet
place also did a great job casting a
talented deaf actress as one of the main
characters where are some in the deaf
community have criticized the silence
for using a hearing actress in the role
of Ally as well as for an inconsistent
and sometimes unrealistic approach to
both signing and lip-reading
as well as the fact there's much more to
being deaf than simply sign language on
the positive side the silence does a
decent job with the design and look of
the vests and they do work quite
effectively on that note if you're
interested in Monster design tap here to
check out my quiet place monsters
explained video so what did you think of
the silence and how it compares to a
quiet place or bird box leave your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this and want more deep dives
subscribe and hit the bell to get all my
new videos tapleft for my quiet place
playlist including deleted scenes and
secrets in the movie or tap write for
another video you're sure to like thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers